what's going on reject nation
i'm gonna put this right up here up
front
i'm gonna want you guys to share this
video because i have a theory
that i firmly believe in i want you to
mark
my words i'm really putting myself out
here on this video
get ready to cut back to this moment
i i really think i'm right about this
one
i trust you i really think i'm right
about this one if you guys don't know
what i'm talking about okay
so recently elizabeth olsen aka
wanda maximoff she was doing an
interview where someone said is luke
skywalker
to appear in this episode and she said
said is there going to be a cameo on the
level of
luke skywalker mandalorian season two
will that will there be some cameo on
that level and
not long ago paul benny was talking
about how there's going gonna be a big
surprise cameo an actor he's always
wanted to work with
it's gonna like really change the
direction of the marvel cinematic
universe or
like combining the quotes of these two
actors who are ruining the element of
surprise for us
you combine these quotes you get
theories about who's gonna appear in
here and now while there's been a lot of
names being thrown around
there's been the same few who have been
thrown into the conversation here and i
have a pretty solid belief as to who
and why it'll be so first i want to talk
about the main people who have been
mentioned
and tell you guys why i don't think it's
going to be them and then
i'm going to tell you guys exactly who i
think it'll be and why and i feel like
you're going to have a hard time arguing
me on it get ready for it that's an
invite get ready for it
okay it's a challenge first one on the
list spider-man
toby maguire spider-man specifically now
our buddy warren over at cosmic wonder
amazing amazing guy i love this guy i
consider him a true friend he put out a
video
this morning actually which is a pretty
compelling argument for why he believes
toby mcguire's spider-man would appear
in wano visual he'll be the big surprise
cameo and he's not the only one who
thinks that when i went on social media
yesterday he was probably the top name
mentioned while i think there's you know
some things you can conclude as to why
especially with the fact of how kevin
feige said
the events of wanda vision will tie in
to doctor strange
and ultimately spider-man 3. i don't
think it'll be him i just don't think
do you think it'll be him no especially
because of that quote i feel like we
already know to expect connective tissue
here and to bring
spider-man toby maguire especially into
this world would only
be neat i feel like it seems like he
would only want to be getting back home
whereas introducing him in a spider-man
movie makes
way more sense to me it makes more sense
it would be a much bigger surprise a
bigger
character impact exactly and that's the
other thing too i don't know what
purpose of a character it would be to
have toby mcguire
like what purpose would he serve i can't
come up with
he forced it into this show i can't
think of any real reason uh spider-man
would be
purposeful for this story i feel like
he'd overshadow and then the other part
that's not really being brought up is
that version of toby maguire or
spider-man is specifically a
sony property spider-man now they have a
deal worked out
with tom holland to be here and so i
could see why you can get it'd be
perfectly fine to let toby mcguire
appear in spider-man 3.
sony has no involvement with one
division no it's not it's not going to
happen guys it's not going to happen and
then there's already all the reports
coming out that like toby mcguire hasn't
even completely finalized his deal for
spider-man 3 whether that's true or not
i just
highly doubt that it's him okay highly
doubt that it's him so i want to cross
him off the list so then it gets you to
the x-men because you got to think about
the quote
especially with the way the question was
asked to elizabeth olsen with the luke
skywalker level you it's an act it has
to be an actor who encompasses not just
a legacy character but an iconic
performance character as well right so
it's like which one of the x-men is it
alan cummings alan cummings ask
nightcrawler
literally john sorry it's just too good
to let it out
supposedly quicksilver is supposed to
appear in this
series i don't care if it's aaron taylor
johnson or evan peters none of them
equal that level of caliber
all right and i don't think any one of
those actors is who paul betty's like
man
i've really been waiting to record
american horror story
no insult to those actors i think
they're both great and i especially love
evan peters i just don't think it's that
same level of caliber and i don't think
it's that kind of iconic
layer that would be as mind-blowing
right i feel like it's a little bit
expected yeah it's so
important to wanda and we've already
seen him in previous yeah
yeah so i don't think it's quick silver
like he can appear in the show but
it's kind of like you have a socatano in
in mandalore and you expected that so
let's go through the list of the x-men
who could be
wolverine now my mind actually went well
i feel like it could possibly be
wolverine that's the first
place my mind went to reason being hugh
jackman did say that
if he were to return as wolverine he'd
wanted to be able to team up with the
avengers or some quote like that but i'm
not
like incorrectly paraphrasing here he
said something like that
also uh when you think about the fact of
how strongly based this is or inspired
by
from house of m wolverine was such an
important part
in that comic he was essentially the
main character you know when you think
about it but i feel like a lot of
the purpose of his role in terms of
helping people you know break away from
the false reality and such
it seems like a lot of that position is
being given to
vision in this series already i don't
think it's going to be him and i'm not
sure how you would smoothly all
make that work i remember that at one
point paul bettany
was supposed to be in les miserables so
i know he would like to work with hugh
jackman
i'm gonna cross them off the list and
another reason why and i can't
really say much about this and it's not
a hundred percent confirmed
but i believe they already femme i'm not
gonna say much but i believe they
already found who their new wolverine
is and i'm gonna just leave it in that
so it's all right i'm just gonna leave
it at that we'll just move right past
that one and the other two main x-men
that came to mind were magneto and
professor x with those two characters
they seem to be probably the ones that
make the most sense between one of those
two
ian mckellen and patrick stewart both
iconic portrayals of
two very iconic importing characters who
were very
important to the story of wanda
in house of m that's our magnio first
ian mckellen okay the main reason why i
don't think it would be ian mckellen
even though there's the fact that
in the comic magneto is wanda's father
so you could get some story tie-ins with
that
sure that makes sense to me you think
about paul bettney's quota of an actor
he's always wanted to work with and i
believe that they didn't they
they worked together in the da vinci
code already yeah i mean i don't know if
they share many scenes directly with
each other but they're both
big characters in that movie yes michael
fossbender is the other pick for magneto
obviously
now i've already heard a bunch of rumors
about how they're looking for michael
fossbender to play a different character
within the marvel cinematic universe
at the same time when you're thinking
about this level of
luke skywalker legacy level backed with
an actor that paul benny's always wanted
to work with sure i could
see him always wanting to have worked
with michael flossman he's an amazing
actor personally i prefer his portrayal
of magneto over
ian mckellen's you could hate me if all
you want for saying that but that's just
my personal opinion i still don't think
he
matches quite that caliber of what we're
talking about and what to expect
and rumor has it they're trying to get
michael fossbender to play a different
character in the marvel cinematic
universe and as much as it would make
sense in terms of him being wanda's
father
i don't see how that can naturally segue
into a finale cameo of sorts
yeah because then you would just be
meeting him for the first time in that
context
yeah so that leads you to professor x
and after much thought my mind concluded
i firmly believe it's gonna be professor
x and here is why
so my mind actually believes and i have
pretty solid reasons as to why i think
it would actually be charles xavier and
not james mcavoy they already worked
together in wimbledon
it's not gonna happen patrick stewart as
charles xavier is some of the most
perfect casting in all of marvel history
there's a wide variety of reasons why i
believe this first off when you look at
the house of m
he was the main guy who was like trying
to keep wanda's [ __ ] under control he
was the main
dude they were using for that when
you're hearing about how
they have to open up the door for
mutants professor x is the main guy to
do that for
and here's the other big kicker this is
from an article that i've pulled up from
movieweb.com that came out january
2021 patrick stewart was being
interviewed and he says
right here right here i met with kevin
feige a couple months ago and we had
long long conversations
and there have been moves and
suggestions which include
charles xavier just look at that
look at that okay so here's what
everyone's gonna say it means the rest
of the quote here's the problem
if we had not made logan then yes i
would probably be ready to get into that
wheelchair one more time be charles
xavier
but logan changed all that first off
that's not a complete denial
secondly even if it is a denial that
don't mean
jack [ __ ] it doesn't let's just go over
a few actors who have flat out lied
about being cast in marvel you got paul
rudd
when asked about ant-man he said it's
all just rumor man
tatiana maslany the most recent one had
this whole thing where she's like that's
just some press release that got out of
hand and then kevin feige does the
disney investor's day he's like yeah we
got tatiana maslany to play
benedict cumberbatch said that it was
just a joke that
he's flat out said i'm not dr strange
after denying playing khan
yes brie larson acted oblivious as to
who captain marvel is
jonathan majors who's recently been
confirmed to play king the conqueror
he was asked about he's like yeah man i
heard the same thing bro actors denying
that they've been
cast and then paul bettany's saying it
has to be someone they kept
under wraps and it hasn't been leaked
and on top of that
paul bettany british actor patrick's too
sir
patrick stewart british british royalty
actor
he's an actor that whenever i hear about
people working with him
every interview of that of a co-star is
like he's an actor i've always wanted to
work with
it's freaking patrick stewart well of
course paul bettany would be in a
position to be like he's an actor i've
always wanted to work with you know when
you tie it into the fact of house of m
the importance of that opening up the
door from mutants the fact that
patrick stewart confirmed that kevin
feige had been meeting with him and
they're trying to get charles xavier
into the marvel cinematic universe and
they were specifically trying to get him
in there everything just lines up for it
to be him
you know they are convincing me actively
in these moments when you think about
like the reality warping the dimension
hopping the capabilities professor x has
story wise paul bettany's quote patrick
stewart's confirmation of the meetings
it's patrick stewart's charles xavier
who else is it gonna be
well and especially yeah hearing yours
and many people's theories that this
show is going to officially
set up the x-men it feels like the
perfect character to do that with
because too when you look at the
longevity on
screen of these movies literally you go
back to the beginning with stuff like
x-men in the early days that really got
superhero movies to be taken seriously
and patrick stewart was
one of the main figures of that and just
him i feel like being cast in that movie
lent at credence at the time and so yeah
you get that legacy
factor even just look at days of future
past who were the characters
from past and future who were able to
talk with each other
young charles and old charles no
other crossover happened in that it was
those
two who talked with each other i'm just
saying the one with the power capability
the one that would make the most sense
especially sending the door when you
look at everything that's been
confirmed reported what paul bettany's
saying iconic
portrayal of the levels of luke
skywalker
it's patrick stewart and if i'm probably
wrong i just don't think i have
to say it yeah all right it's gonna be
him
guys who do you think it'll be do you
agree with me leave your thoughts down
below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
adelia chamberlain i know that out of
anyone at our patreon the one who would
want the ability
to re-warp her whole home life right now
it would definitely be you i want you to
know though but in the current reality
you live in you still have two people
here
who love the [ __ ] out of you you have
meant so much
to us you have been incredibly helpful
i go to bat for you woman and i will die
for you
oh yeah john would immediately die for
you i would i'm
trying i would question whether or not
dying for you but i probably would
if there was a camera pointed at me and
i could be famous for doing it
but just know that you rock my socks
you're an incredible friend and i hope
2021 is a much better year for you and i
hope you're enjoying one division
[Music]